As we talk about algorithms, we're going to talk about 2 costs.
The first is step complexity, and the second is work complexity.
So as an example here we have 8 elements that we'd like to combine using this tree style structure.
And so we're going to try to characterize the number of steps
that it's going to take us to do this computation as well as the total amount of work.
So first we're going to look at the number of steps.
We see that it's going to take us 3 steps to finish.
This first step here we'll do 4 operations,
the second step can be done in parallel with 2 operations,
and then the third step is a final operation to get a final result.
But we can also count the total amount of work that we've done here.
We've done 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7 operations.
So we'd say the step complexity is 3 and the work complexity is 7.
So we'll compare the step and work complexity of the parallel implementations that we develop
against the step and work complexity for a serial implementation.
And 1 more piece of terminology.
We will say that a parallel algorithm is work-efficient.
If it's work complexity, it's asymptotically the same,
so within a constant factor as the work complexity of the sequential algorithm.
Now if we can reduce the step complexity in our parallel implementation
compared to the serial implementation
while still having a reasonable work complexity that isn't too expensive,
we expect that this will lead to faster runtime overall.
So the real key here is to formulate the most efficient parallel algorithm,
and that's the focus of this lecture and the next lecture.